wo ist dein ding
[Musik]
du wirst du das zimmer anschauen
ja so war neue wege und telefoniert ich
bin dieser brunner cool das ist die
wohnung dieser machen möchte dein zimmer
sehen
ich bin nur wenn freut mich raus mit ok
dann die fenster sind groß und deshalb
die vierzimmerwohnung es gibt fünf
zimmer eine küche und ein wartet ja dann
kommen wir mit
[Musik]
das zimmer ist vielleicht auch ganz
schön groß ich für die parameter hat das
thema denn ich glaube das hat zehn
quadratmeter oder das zimmer hat elf
quadratmeter ja und es ist sehr ruhig
keine autos so das ist eine küche die
küche ist ja wie möglich hier sitzen wir
oft wie teuer ist
die miete kostet mit nebenkosten 400
euro im monat
ok ich nehme das zimmer es kommen noch
andere interessenten aber wir rufen
nicht nur cool
[Musik]